you have worked with ashley benson now
on two different songs
will she be featured on this upcoming
ooh i like how you smile right there
she's an exceptionally talented person
she's a special one
i've experienced love in my life and
i've experienced heartbreak in my life
and i've caused heartbreak in my life
[Music]
yeah i know i'm crazy but you're sick
too so excited for
the release of this song because it has
been stuck in my head
all day it's called hate the way um
first of all is this the lead single off
the new album
yeah yeah this is this is the um the all
hands on deck
you know this is the big bazooka this is
the lead single this is the beginning of
you know an album that i'm really
excited about i've spent the last two
years working on
you know we're really excited to get the
ball rolling why do you feel like this
song was the right song to sort of lead
lead the charge of this new era
well because my friend black bear's on
it
it just feels like a special song and i
think also
ironically we didn't intend it this way
but it speaks to the times
you know we're all missing a lot about
the life that
you know we've been separated from you
know whether it's a person that you miss
whether it's
you know going outside and seeing
friends whether it's you know whatever
um there's a lot of separation in the
world right now
and with separation often comes
missing that thing that you're away from
what do you feel like it is about your
connection musically that keeps bringing
you guys
back together for these these
collaborations
i mean i think certain people just have
a creative chemistry and also
you know just being friends outside of
music anytime you you actually like the
people you get to work with it's always
a plus you know that's true and i also
feel like it's a certain type of record
that we always do together and it's
always just this artsy left field record
for kind of both of us
i can't seem to find out what's the
issue see your face on my explorer and
then i'll miss you
i did the lyrics for this song come
about i mean did you sort of write it
all g and then bring him
in or was he like oh i have the perfect
chorus for this well
versus you know i try to verses are a
lot more wordy than choruses sometimes
sometimes i get too wordy but i use the
verses as a chance to tell a really like
in-depth
like portrayal of a story or a person or
a you know a feeling
and the hook should be able to kind of
like sum that all up and i think that's
what he did so brilliantly
with the chorus and the emotion he gave
it and the way he's saying it
you know there's this authenticity and
this vulnerability and this really human
emotion that
you know it was brought to him yeah i
know i'm crazy but you're sick too
even after everything we've been through
i can't help but feel that this
song is perhaps a little bit
autobiographical
what did inspire it well
you know
um uh you know i'm a human being as well
and you know i've i've experienced love
in
my life and i've experienced heartbreak
in my life
and i've caused heartbreak in my life
and i received heartbreak in my life
and you know the power of music is to
kind of express and capture
the human experience you know we live
and we experience things and then
music for us is you know as an outlet as
a way to
to channel that you know the things that
we go through and put it into some
tangible form that you know i try not to
make it too strictly autobiographical
because i want it to be relatable to
everyone you know anybody so i want it
to to be a way that can be applied to
you know things that a lot of people go
through what about the concept
of the video how did you guys sort of
hash out how that would
look just because it is really dark and
it's sad and it's
heartbreaking it's kind of intense right
when i first saw the treatment i was
like what is this even about and then
once
once i finally got on set and we shot
the first scene of me
even took an hour they wanted to get it
that perfect and i was like okay this is
the wavelength they're on there
they're on some we have to have this
very theatrical and perfect
yeah yeah and i mean we wanted it to
feel cinematic period
just wanted to tell a story of you know
a tumultuous toxic
relationship between people that go
south you know find a way to do it
cinematically and not make it too dark
obviously
um but for it to be real you know and
you know even aside from relationships
even aside from
you know whatever i think a lot of
people are going through a really
difficult time right now
um it's been eight months of you know
confusing
time you know of being apart from each
other staying inside
you know trying to follow these
guidelines and you know take care of
each other and look out for each other
but doing it from a distance while
you know mental health is is you know
been
an issue with a lot of people and you
know substance use and abuse
and all these different things that you
know people
you know people gravitate towards in in
in
difficult times all this pain wishing it
was something that could fix it medicate
myself different substances i mix it
set my limits try to draw the line and
then she sniffs it this song
is i mean incredibly deep and it does
deal with
i feel like difficult big issues there's
a line in the song that says medicate
myself
different substances i mix i try to draw
the line and then she
sniffs it
[Laughter]
you said it so poetically i mean yeah i
didn't wrap it as good as you do but
kind of talk to me about that line and i
guess do you ever
second guess including some of these
darker themes
in your song and is music kind of a way
to i guess
process personal things that maybe
you're going through
music is of course an outlet and a way
to process personal things i'm going
through
and i never want to you know
bite my tongue or hold back when it
comes to my creative approach
you have to be mindful and considerate
of you know
if you're doing something that you want
to share with the world
you know being sensitive of all that but
at the same time i think the creative
process should be free
and not held back and you should be able
to write you know anything whether it's
completely autobiographical and personal
or whether it's
you know whether it's you know writing
stories
come on chill
listen to me come on baby so
boring where do you draw the line on
addressing something that's personal
just keeping something totally to
yourself
do you ever struggle with that yeah
absolutely because at the end of the day
i'm a human being with a real life and
real family and real
loved ones as well and you know it gets
hard sometimes when you're in the public
eye
you know how to close that window into
your private personal home
yeah you know and keep things that are
near and dear to you
yours and not share them with the world
all the time
sure and that goes for everything not
just the darker sides but even if you're
in love and sometimes you just want to
preserve and protect something that
you're sharing with somebody and not
you know or it's like not sharing your
whole entire family with
the internet you know and like just
keeping some of that protected
that's a good point that you bring up
even when you're happier you're in love
or whatever
do you find it more difficult to have
those types of relationships in the
public eye because you do want to keep
them
sort of safe for both of you i do
yeah i think i think
i definitely think i like to like i like
to go through a bunch of wreckage in my
life and then i like to
work through it with my therapist work
through it with my family and then
pull from it later in in songs and talk
about it when it's in the past
tense and then maybe talk about it like
it's going on right now in my life and
that's just um
and that's just like uh that's that's
how i proc that's how i
draw the line if it's if it's okay to
talk about like
i don't like to write a song and put it
out as as something's going on that's
what's happening absolutely
yeah and it's the ability to go through
the wreckage and
recover from it you know through therapy
and then find ways to you know to to
let that you know let those experiences
transmit and transcend
you know through your art form um some
people will assume that this song
or this video i guess i should say is
about
possibly a past tumultuous
relationship and i feel like we've seen
easter eggs
in the past how does it feel when people
do assume
songs are about an x what or another
song is about you like how does that
mean well
i mean what are you supposed to do as a
creative stop writing from the heart or
stop
writing all together stop doing music
videos
stop doing what you do no i mean you
know creative freedom and
pull from somewhere you got to pull from
somewhere and and we're allowed to
we're allowed to write you know this is
our purpose and what we do
you sign an oath you take on an
understanding of you know
what you signed up for when you get into
this business that
what people what conclusions people draw
and what people take from
it is out of your control yeah this
can't you can't control the way people
react or perceive or you know experience
your artwork all you can do is
make what you want to make say it from
the heart put it out there and
understand that
past that point as soon as i click
upload it's out of my control
yeah have you ever felt blindsided by a
song someone wrote about
you either of you anyone ever write a
song about you
yeah is that a plea to say
no i don't know i don't know yeah i
don't know i don't know if like but i've
had
i've had inclinations before like this
sounds like something that happened but
i don't think the the person's never
came forward and been like this is about
you
what can you tease about the rest of the
album
it's is it a sequel to these things
happening
yeah yeah these things happen too uh
it's really about
you know this full circle journey i've
started making music when i was a little
kid selling music in downtown oakland
out of a backpack
i've always had these big ambitions and
i'm grateful that music has taken me all
around the world which feels like from
the bay to the universe to me so this is
about
you know that spaceship coming back and
landing back home
and it being a full circle journey so
big for me was working with a lot of the
people that i made the first one with
like black bear who was
he did two songs on the first album with
me i've been reminding people that
you know on this journey i didn't lose
myself or forget who i was and then
make you know music that's like
sonically resemblance of
you know where it all started i just
realized you didn't ask me to do the
intro on this one so it better be a good
intro
before i turn it in i might have to i
might have to add you to have you add
some vocals or some trunks
i was gonna say is there a second song
with him on this one well
it's not completely turned in yet so you
never know i've done 350 songs so far
i'm not i'm not mad at doing 351.
three wait you've recorded 350 and you
have to narrow it down to what like 14
tracks yeah
yeah pretty much how do you do that it's
really hard killing babies man i love
them all
that is what it's like though you write
a song very much you care so much about
it
um you have worked with ashley benson
now on two different songs
will she be featured on this upcoming
ooh i like how you smile right there
you'll just have to wait and see is you
standing right there
she's not here right now
what what is it like to work with her
and also to be with her in a romantic
capacity what's
the difference there uh she's an
exceptionally talented person
um in many different spaces she's a
special one
obviously she's a great actress but you
know getting to work with her and
putting in front of a microphone and
watching her sing so effortlessly
and she has this very special tone of
voice and texture and something that's
very innate to her given that it's not
her
you know it's not her like first you
know job or what she's known
for it just blew me away that you could
have such a hidden
you know special talent that the world
doesn't you know get to see as often
do you guys write together like have you
written songs together
yeah what what do they sound like what
are they about
they sound like what they sound like and
they're in my studio
and you know maybe one day they'll see
the light of day we'll see
okay well hopefully one of those will
make make that cut
how has quarantine life been for each of
you
guys what's been the biggest life
adjustment for
for both of you i mean i'm a new dad so
i'm just like i'm just like
chasing around a little kid that knows
how to crawl and is biting everything
and he has four teeth and
he's like starting to talk and stuff so
i quarantine for me has been a little
easier i feel like because
i'm like preoccupied like now i'm um
you know water painting color painting
on the bathroom floor
and of the bathtub and like doing all
playing with cereal
are you enjoying fatherhood do you see
like a shift in yourself
becoming a new dad for sure yeah my
priorities are totally
are totally changed and everything like
that i i go to bed at like 8 30 or 9
every day uh gee watching your friend
become a dad
do you one day want to become a dad
ah we shall see you can't fast forward
the movie you know you gotta watch it
the whole way through
we'll see you guys folks and wishes it
must be exciting for you
yeah it's very exciting it's very
exciting and seeing the change in him
and i was telling the other day when he
posted the video listening third eye
blinds like holding his
i mean it gosh it's just like it warms
your heart for sure
yeah and you know seeing seeing the
change in him and
yeah yeah i mean one day who knows
you